[Music]
can you get on the other church I can
prop my feet back up my legs are a
beauty queen just because it's your
wedding doesn't mean you get what you
want
yeah it does mean that this is pumpkins
day I know this all I got to say is Gina
I better stay focused on pumpkin today
if she even thinks about ambush and Gina
for a wedding
I won't choke the living daylights out
of her is your dress ready you're like
my great-grandmother talking about
dresses let's go we gotta get your
bridesmaids dress on jeans all concerned
about fitting into a pageant dress yeah
think she'd be more concerned about
fitting into the dress that she's gonna
wear to the wedding let's see if it fits
last time I looked at the scale I
weighed over 200 pounds I know pumpkin
before she ordered the bridesmaids dress
she checked with JJ about his size so
I'm sure since I was 18
hopefully all those all-you-can-eat
buffets haven't done too much damage he
didn't get a puppy turn thighs seriously
June turn your ass around oh [ __ ] God
why my hands always up in you're shoving
in my butt wiggle it in come on this is
the magic bag we have Spanx we will
spank that ass into their mom and her
back aides are gonna ruin my way
seriously oh my god come on say it in
girls oh my god
[Music]